Remember that our program is mostly funded
by individual memberships, one of which you
can get at, join Pakman dot com coupon code.
Fresh Start is available for those who want
it.
The pardons are starting in the latest sign
that no matter what Donald Trump says publicly,
he knows his days as president are numbered.
And Donald Trump has pardoned his former national
security adviser, the convicted Michael Flynn.
Now, remember that Michael Flynn pleaded guilty
to lying to the FBI about contact with Russian
officials.
Trump announcing the pardon, of course, via
Twitter just hours before Thanksgiving, saying,
quote, It is my great honor to announce that
General Michael T. Flynn has been granted
a full pardon, no partial pardon for Michael
Flynn, a full pardon.
Congratulations to General Flynn and his wonderful
family.
I know you will now have a truly fantastic
Thanksgiving.
Remember that Donald Trump has already commuted
the sentence of his former campaign aide,
Roger Stone.
He's expected to pardon many more people between
now and January 20th.
And on the table could be pardons for Paul
Manafort, George Papadopoulos.
Steve Bannon has been charged but not yet
convicted.
Rudy Giuliani is under federal investigation
for possibly breaking lobbying laws.
There are many others.
Now, on the one hand, you would be absolutely
correct to say these aren't just mere presidential
pardons for crimes committed that have nothing
to do with the president himself, for better
or worse.
These are not traditional or standard pardons
in the sense that many of the people that
are potentially going to get pardons and some
who did get pardons already, their crimes
relate to Donald Trump's own campaign or administration,
or they relate to telling lies to help Donald
Trump.
So you are completely right.
If your reaction is this is not, you know,
pardoning someone who's been in prison for
20 years for something you think is unfair.
These are pardons related to crimes committed
as part of Donald Trump's campaign transition
team or administration.
You would be completely right now, at the
same time, I'm seeing people talking about
Trump needs to suffer the consequences for
doing this.
He can't be allowed to get away with pardoning
these people who in many cases committed crimes
that were meant to help hide the possible
wrongdoing of Donald Trump.
My advice is, don't even bother.
Look, I hate to be saying this, but we've
got seven weeks left in this administration.
There is no chance that Donald Trump will
have any negative repercussions from making
these pardons.
My recommendation is save your energy and
your focus and your sanity and get to something
else, because it's disgusting for me to be
saying it, because it's the reality in the
United States.
But he's going to get away with these pardons,
as corrupt as they may be.
Now, there is also the story here of Donald
Trump's hypocrisy.
Remember when Donald Trump explained firing
Michael Flynn?
He also did that via Twitter, where he said
back in 2017, I had to fire General Flynn
because he lied to the vice president and
the FBI.
He has pled guilty to those lies.
It is a shame because his actions during the
transition were lawful.
There was nothing to hide.
Trump isn't pardoning Flynn, at least apparently,
because he wasn't really guilty.
Trump concedes that Flynn did the thing he
was convicted of.
Trump simply thinks it should be lawful.
He's pardoning Flynn for other reasons, presuming
that he believes Flynn kept him out of trouble
to some degree.
Now, if you really want to take a trip down
the delusional recesses of the Internet, there
were pro Trump forums that when Donald Trump
pardoned Michael Flynn on Wednesday, they
immediately started posting.
Trump pardoned Flynn because Flynn is the
last puzzle piece in overturning the election
results to get Donald Trump a second term.
Just unbelievable delusions taking place.
And think now of the full Michael Flynn story.
As we understand it, during the transition,
Barack Obama told Donald Trump, I would not
hire Michael Flynn.
He's a national security risk.
Trump says I'm going to hire him anyway and
makes him national security adviser.
Flynn lies to the FBI, was an unregistered
foreign agent, lied about his contacts with
Russia, et cetera.
Trump fires him and concedes.
Flynn lied, yeah, he's he he did it, he's
guilty.
Flynn then helps Robert Mueller in his investigation,
which leads to Robert Mueller recommending
no jail time for Flynn.
Flynn then recants the testimony on which
the no jail time recommendation was made and
incomes Donald Trump and pardons Michael Flynn.
It it would be almost unbelievable as a screenplay
for a movie about Washington, D.C. corruption.
But it's real.
I mean, is Flynn the luckiest guy in the world
or is there a different way that we should
be thinking about it?
Absolutely unbelievable.
The the pardons will be coming.
And I am as a curious as you about who will
be
on
that list.